cuántas veces han escuchado esta frase
somos más los buenos
que les inspiraron estas imágenes 17 de
octubre culiacán sinaloa yo creo que a
muchos de nosotros nos inspiró miedo
enojo todos los sentimientos encontrados
a la vez
a mí me provocó una sensación muy
desagradable porque el cartel de sinaloa
tuvo en calidad de segundos la capacidad
de movilizar a una enorme cantidad de
personas
y dirigir un ataque en contra del estado
mexicano
y me preocupo bastante que la imagen que
se conoce de méxico internacionalmente
sea este tipo de imagen este tipo de
sucesos
los narcotraficantes hoy en día se ha
convertido en un tema muy de moda hasta
series tenemos en la televisión sobre
los narcos y esta no es la imagen del
méxico el méxico que yo amo ni es la
imagen de las personas extraordinarias
que yo conozco que día con día
transforman este país
por eso cuando escucho la frase somos
más los buenos no puedo estar más de
acuerdo efectivamente somos más los
buenos sin embargo me preocupa muchísimo
un factor que nos falta un factor
poderoso y este factor podría ser la
diferencia la organización los buenos no
estamos organizados creo firmemente que
méxico tiene todo el potencial toda la
capacidad para hacer un país
desarrollado sin desigualdad social con
paz con bienestar y esta creencia no la
estoy basando en utopías o en sueños en
los últimos siete años yo he estado
trabajando directamente con personas
aquí en nuevo léon que transforman las
calles las colonias que transforman la
realidad de nuestro estado y ese trabajo
con organizaciones y con personas
realmente me ha permitido cambiar
completamente de parecer sobre lo que yo
creo que es el principal factor de
desarrollo para nuestro país
estoy convencida que el arma secreta de
mexico para alcanzar su pleno desarrollo
y bienestar es precisamente la sociedad
civil organizada los miles y miles de
ciudadanos que se levantan todos los
días para hacer el bien y para hacerlo
bien por esto quisiera hoy visibilizar
con ustedes el día de hoy esta tribu del
bien que transforma el país cómo se
movilizan los ciudadanos en méxico
primero quisiera clarificar algunos
conceptos cuando nos referimos al primer
sector el primer sector es el gobierno
todo el gobierno en sus tres niveles
cuando hablamos del segundo sector
hablamos de las empresas y la iniciativa
privada y el tercer sector precisamente
se refiere a todas aquellas
organizaciones de la sociedad civil este
colectivos redes juntas vecinales bien
todas las personas que se agrupan de
manera voluntaria
este tercer sector ocupa una posición
intermedia entre el gobierno y las
empresas y no persigue fines de lucro
tampoco persigue fines religiosos o
partidistas
de acuerdo con jacqueline butcher que es
una investigadora muy reconocida aquí en
este tema el tercer sector busca la
consecución del bien común hacer frente
a las necesidades humanas y promover la
participación de la sociedad
de acuerdo con los datos más recientes
que tiene el cemefi en méxico habría
unas 44 mil 750 organizaciones de la
sociedad civil pero no es la única forma
de movilizar a la ciudadanía para
transformar a nuestro país también se
realizan al año un poco más de dos
millones de acciones de voluntariado
alrededor del país de acuerdo con el
inegi y este trabajo voluntario genera
un enorme valor para nuestro país se
estima en el 2017 que el valor económico
del trabajo voluntario fue de más de 128
mil millones de pesos además de este
trabajo voluntario las organizaciones de
sociedad civil le dan trabajo en méjico
a un millón y medio de personas y todas
estas personas y organizaciones
contribuimos al pib de nuestro país
también les quisiera platicar un tema
muy importante el efecto multiplicador
que tienen los donativos o las
aportaciones que se hacen a estas
organizaciones de sociedad civil en
méxico por cada peso que se dona a una
organización de la sociedad civil el
estado mexicano deja de percibir 30
centavos sin embargo este peso que se
dona una organización de la sociedad
civil se estima que tiene un valor un
retorno sobre inversión social de 4.70
pesos entonces la próxima vez que
quieran invertir su dinero en una buena
causa piénsenlo muy bien este donar no
duele lo que quisiera enfatizar mucho
cuando ustedes el día de hoy es esta
convicción personal que yo tengo que las
organizaciones de sociedad civil son el
arma secreta de mexico para fortalecer
su democracia y el bienestar somos más
los buenos efectivamente para construir
este sueño de paz democracia y justicia
que tenemos para el país
más allá de solamente atender personas
vulnerables o beneficiarios las
organizaciones civiles contribuyen de
manera significativa a la democracia de
nuestros país de nuestro país porque
hacen avanzar causas ciudadanas
trascendentales por ejemplo elecciones
libres y democráticas transparencia
rendición de cuentas lucha contra la
corrupción protección de los derechos
humanos todas estas causas las hacen
avanzar desde la sociedad civil
organizada las organizaciones civiles
también han sido unos contrapesos
fundamentales contra los abusos del
poder político y en ciertas ocasiones
contra los abusos de algunas empresas
por este rol de contrapeso y la
incidencia pública que tienen en nuestra
comunidad es que yo creo que las
organizaciones civiles son un factor
clave de gobernanza democrática entonces
quisiera ejemplificar un poco lo que les
estoy diciendo con dos casos dos casos
de aquí de nuevo léon orgullosamente
van a ver cómo pueden efectivamente las
organizaciones civiles provocar cambios
aquí en lo local pero también en lo
nacional el primer caso que les quiero
presentar es la sucesión renace renace
nace hace unos 25 años en nuevo léon
visitando reclusorio y brindando un
apoyo jurídico a personas vulnerables
que han sido encarceladas injustamente
la iniciativa nace de abogados y
empresarios y deciden actuar en ese
terreno porque se han dado cuenta de las
grandes injusticias de nuestro sistema
penal sin embargo a lo largo de su
existencia
rena se va mucho más allá que
simplemente atender a personas
vulnerables también se está metiendo en
un tema importantísimo para todos
nosotros todos los que están aquí
sentados el día de hoy que es detonar el
mayor proceso de transformación de
justicia en nuestro país
renace desde el año 2004 se empezó a
meter en temas de incidencia pública
para poder cambiar la forma en que se
llevan los juicios en el estado de nuevo
léon y en el 2004 es cuando se empiezan
a llevar a cabo juicios orales en
nuestro estado pero no se quedaron ahí
en el 2008 en conjunto con la red
nacional de juicios orales lograron la
aprobación de una reforma constitucional
a nivel nacional que permitió la
transformación estructural de nuestro
sistema de justicia penal y de seguridad
pública esa transformación realmente es
considerada como una de las más
trascendentes en los últimos años en
méxico a lo largo de su vida
la organización renal se ha atendido a
más de 26.000 personas vulnerables pero
tan solo en el año 2018
reyna se atendió a 2 mil 773 personas y
miren el impacto que genera la atención
de renace se estimó que el año pasado
con esta atención de renace el estado
méxico estado de nuevo léon se ahorró
142 millones de pesos y las familias de
estas
de estas personas encarceladas dos
millones y medio de pesos entonces ese
es el impacto que genera una
organización de sociedad civil
el segundo caso que les quiero presentar
es el caso de cada que cada que se crea
en los años noventas con el objetivo de
atender a violaciones de derechos
humanos que sucedían día con día a
nuestro estado sin embargo las cosas se
pusieron más complicadas a partir del
año 2009 cada que empieza a recibir las
primeras los primeros reportes de
desaparición de personas entonces qué
hizo cada que no se quedó de brazos
cruzados cada que empezó a generar una
relación directa una interlocución
directa con la procuraduría de justicia
de nuestro estado para empezar a revisar
los expedientes de cada una de estas
personas en conjunto con sus familias
desde el 2009
cada que ha tenido ha mantenido un
registro de personas desaparecidas en
nuestro estado a la fecha de hoy suman
mil 491 personas desaparecidas en nuevo
léon gracias al trabajo de cada se
pudieron encontrar a 181 de esas
personas desaparecidas 98 con registros
de dna y 83 con vida también lograron
que 23
fueran sentenciadas en el estado de
nuevo león por el delito de desaparición
forzada de personas gracias a su
incansable labor lograron el
reconocimiento en el código penal de
nuestro estado del delito de
desaparición forzada de personas y
gracias a esta labor que realiza cada en
el 2017 se pudo modificar una ley a
nivel nacional que se llama la ley
general en materia de esa desaparición
forzada
entonces el día de hoy solamente les
puedo presentar estos dos casos no tengo
mucho tiempo para hablar de más pero
podría contarles decenas de historias de
casos de sociedad civil organizada en el
estado de nuevo léon que igual que
renace igual que cada que están
transformando las realidades todos los
días están transformando nuestra
democracia cualquier democracia necesita
los tres sectores los tres sectores
interdependientes fuertes con relaciones
entre sí el tercer sector no puede
faltar en este balance de lo contrario
estaríamos condenados a vivir en una
democracia imperfecta esto no es algo
nuevo y no lo estoy inventando el yo el
día de hoy lo estudio a fondo un
filósofo francés que se llamaba top vil
hace casi 200 años cuando visitó américa
es esencial no solo pensar en cómo
fortalecer a cada uno de los tres
sectores sino también buscar formas
efectivas de colaboración entre ellos
para contribuir al desarrollo de méxico
y precisamente les quiero platicar un
poco de las dificultades a las cuales se
enfrentan las organizaciones de sociedad
civil en nuestro país
para empezar todavía son muy poquitas
méxico es uno de los países del
continente con la menor densidad de
organizaciones de sociedad civil por
cada 100.000 habitantes como lo pueden
constatar en esta gráfica aquí en nuevo
león de acuerdo con algunos registros
que tenemos para poder medir esto habría
unas 800 26 organizaciones registradas
ante el indesol y solamente 537 que
tienen una autorización para recibir
donativos del sat considerando la
cantidad y la magnitud de los problemas
que todavía tenemos que atender en este
estado yo considero que son muy poquitas
también abre hay otro problema a las
cuales se enfrentan las organizaciones a
pesar de todas las acciones positivas
que realizan por la comunidad como les
platiqué hace ratito las organizaciones
civiles siguen enfrentando una gran
desconfianza por parte de la población y
ese es un problema generalizado en
méxico no solamente aquí en nuevo léon
por ejemplo en los resultados de una
encuesta muy reciente que se realizó
aquí en el estado pueden ver que
solamente el 22 por ciento de las
personas entrevistadas contestaron que
tenían confianza en las organizaciones
de sociedad civil también enfrentan
otros problemas la insuficiencia de
fondos provenientes de filantropía o de
gobierno la necesidad de profesionalizar
su trabajo la falta de certidumbre
laboral es de los bajos salarios en el
sector la alta rotación en el sector y
es también la falta de leyes y programas
o políticas públicas específicas de
fomento a sus actividades
entonces pues el día de hoy les quiero
dejar un mensaje de esperanza pero
también un mensaje de urgencia si si
somos más los buenos de esto no me queda
ninguna duda a mí este sin embargo nos
falta mucho más organización que se
puede demostrar como cuando se organiza
una comunidad puede lograr cambios
importantísimos para las personas
vulnerables transformar nuestra
democracia transformar los problemas
verdaderamente estructurales de nuestro
país y desde hoy yo creo que es posible
cambiar esta realidad si cada uno de los
que están aquí presentes decide tomar
acción
entonces les quiero invitar les quiero
invitar a sumarse al bien organizado
vamos a hacer crecer juntos el tercer
sector en méxico y les voy a dar unas
cuatro recomendaciones que podrían
seguir a partir del día de hoy para que
cada uno de nosotros concretamente
podamos hacer algo
primero les invito a conocer el trabajo
y la labor de las organizaciones civiles
en nuestro estado en nuestro país de
seguro hay una organización que realiza
un trabajo en algún área que para
ustedes es importante entonces acercarse
con ellos rompan esta barrera la
desconfianza conozcan el trabajo que
están haciendo
les invito a difundir información
positiva sobre la labor de las
organizaciones de sociedad civil todo el
tiempo hay actividades que realizan
estas organizaciones campañas a favor de
alguna causa pero necesitan más difusión
más reconocimiento y más visibilidad de
su trabajo entonces se pueden sumar a
campañas aquí hay dos campañas vigentes
ahorita a nivel nacional y en el estado
de nuevo léon que les invito a conocer y
les invito a apoyar
también yo creo que puedan hacer un
donativo como les decía donar no duele
los dos los donativos en mexico se
pueden deducir de sus impuestos hasta en
un 7 por ciento de sus ingresos y como
les comentaba todo lo que don dan a una
organización de la sociedad civil
verdaderamente se va a multiplicar
y finalmente pues le quiero les quiero
invitar a sumarse a alguna actividad de
voluntariado puedan descubrir cómo donar
un poquito de ustedes mismos para ayudar
a los demás verdaderamente los va a
transformar en lo personal entonces yo
les invito a ser ciudadanos
de tiempo completo de 365 días al año y
yo creo que si se involucran de esta
manera podríamos todos verdaderamente
cambiar esta imagen que se tiene de
méxico en el extranjero y que se conozca
lo bueno que hay en mexico se conozca lo
bueno que es la gente que vive en este
país cómo se involucra y cómo lucha por
las causas que les preocupa y para
finalizar como dijo facundo cabral los
buenos somos mayoría pero no se nota
porque las cosas buenas son humildes y
silenciosas una bomba hace más ruido que
una caricia pero por cada bomba hay
millones de caricias que construyen la
vida muchas gracias
[Aplausos]